it's fun okay i'm with it what's up
brandon what's up theo
this is evan from alabama uh brandon and
i'm probably going to be
joining the thick boy bike club pretty
soon because you know papa's getting a
little chubby
well anyway i got the bait club
uh so i was in the army rest in peace
shelby jones
and my uncle was in the navy and i was
wondering
who y'all got army versus navy uh
football games coming up so everybody's
gonna be you know
talking trash and all that so anyway i
appreciate y'all boys y'all get me
through the work week
and uh gang gang buzz buzz buzz buzz
young man come on now go
navy dog only navy up in here my papo's
in the navy really
yeah grandpa's in the army come from
military family but it's go navy around
here
you look like a little navy guy right
now yeah i'll be your sailor hey
oh okay i'm not even on a boat sir
okay so um i'm gonna say that
you know army here's the thing man we
all know the marines do the real heavy
lifting
okay the grunts yeah and then the army
navy comes in
navy seals army green rangers
party what else uh
you got the the army rangers you got the
navy seals
you have the air force marine raiders
space force oh the green berets yup
space forces
yeah i mean they're all great who am i
for
i don't know which one i'd rather i get
kind of seasick after a while dude and
if i'm going to countries on a boat i'm
going to
end up buying coke man whereas if i'm
just stuck at a base then i probably
will
be able to relax suck a level c have you
ever done a
you do a lot of coke or no no you know
i know where to find it huh i said i
know where to find it well i'm gonna
have to have the communication there
because my friend has a problem
i'll take it get out brendan yeah you
find it just no that's enough
of that he smelled it on you when you
walked in
what can i say i'm a mexican sorry and
do mexicans do a lot of cocaine you
think
um i don't know about that i i would say
in my community the problem that we had
was more like
meth so what's that i mean wait where
are you from again i'm from lincoln
heights here in los
angeles where's that at it's like border
of east la
and kind of highland park pasadena area
and do i never thought mexican people
did meth do they really
i mean it was just in my community and
it was like my family members
so that's kind of what i'm referencing
right math more of a
lower income thing is it yes they call
it uh broken windows right yeah
it's huge where i'm from in arizona i
think beth is big everywhere in all
ethnic cities
white boys love math that's true that's
why they're missing his teeth and [ __ ]
that's true
now is there a kind of a drug if you
notice have you ever been around men
that are trying to have sex or do sex
and do you think that these men what's
their drug of choice if they're getting
involved would it be like the molly
maybe
ecstasy what are they trying to do you
can't go to the strip club
brendan i feel like they're usually
drunk
i think it's what it really is i feel
like if you're on coke you can't
really get harder yeah come or anything
like that so they're probably
drunk i would assume i don't know maybe
they're high
probably mostly either high or drunk
most of the people
i figured those are the only options
also
or if you're a real professional at that
strip club you come in sweats do a
little molly and have a great time
you know that i've definitely seen that
once or twice oh yeah you and if you
guys in sweaty they're for one thing
and who was who was one of the biggest
celebrities that came to the
cheetahs you feel like a regular besides
john lovitz
what's his i think name caught him
but um what's his name he's one of the
sprouse twins i think
i believe it was dylan i believe it was
dylan sprouse
like the cooler one all those uh younger
kids
oh some disney stars up in there huh
disney stars he would bring his friends
all the time he's a real sweetie he was
like you know
did he tip he was cheering us on yeah
him and his friends always tipped well
and they would never see anything
disrespectful they was like look at you
go girl yeah
i bet you wish you kept some of that
money though huh
one of them is still an actor now he's
on riverdale
the other one i think he's back in
acting now too they took time off
because they wanted to go to college
god get off their nuts are they are you
successful
you're in wikipedia brendan they're
successful yeah what are you talking
about successful young men
they were the kids in uh oh [ __ ] they
were the kids
yes oh wow they're also the kids i love
them yeah they were also the kids in
like what was that tv show they were on
for 10 years
yeah what was it sweet life of zach and
coach they could have easily been
molested brendan from that show alone
for life honestly oh yeah 100 now dude
they came in together and tip well
no it's just one that's a bummer you
want to see both of them if they're
gonna come out
i mean i kind of feel like you can tell
one of them's got the good boy vibe one
of them got the bad boy
angel demon yeah so you know the demon
was up in there on his demon time
that's probably the one who was accused
of having a small dick
oh my god oh one yeah you know way too
much about him cat
no yeah they're like in my age group you
can't go hard on miley cyrus and halsey
and i can't go hard on the
the sprost go ahead i didn't know they
were famous
yeah they're like my generation one of
them went to college they dated a girl
they broke up and she like released his
dick pic or something and his brother
his brother tweeted out like thanks now
everyone knows what my dick looks like
too yeah
we got the same same you know nick at
night
i keep my dick at my house good for you
that's my rule that's good can't lose
your dick no on the streets
but does that mean you can send a pick
if it's from your house of your dick
what i'll do is i got a friend of mine
named jason and i'll have he
lent me his dick he has a sticker via
photo and i'll send a couple of those
out yeah
we call that honeydecking um
now did cheetah serve food because it's
always an interesting thing because i'm
always hungry
so it's interesting to me when you get
to the strip club and have good food
they had like nuts on the counter oh i'd
known yeah we know that we're talking
about food
i had some nuts for you to gobble you
know yeah no but there we go because
there's plenty there's a place called
magic
in atlanta and they're notoriously known
for the food city chicken wings
yeah i want to go so bad was there was
there other clubs that once you were
working in an
exotic type of club was there other
clubs where you wanted to then like go
work at like
you know like like oh that place sounds
cool i'd like to be able to try that
like what was the pinnacle of strip
clubs in l.a well for me the pinnacle
was truly it was uh
jumbos and cheetahs jumbos jumbos i
thought that was heavier set girls
no jumbos no
jumbo's clown room jumbo's clown room oh
yeah i mean we would have actually we
had a bbw night at cheetahs
oh you did yeah how was that i never
went but it was real bbws i don't know
if you know what real baby tommy's
looked like
yeah we did 100 real bbws we were just
looking at lizards
and we also have chappelle and brendan
yeah we're here we're bbm
bbm big beautiful man bbm's big
beautiful
but uh yeah they got all you guys
sometimes you gotta like a thick girl
you know with them big old titties yeah
there we go you're pulling it up there
we go some of those breasts they just
they
they so long though yeah they're almost
too much for me
i don't like it where it looks like
somebody nailed a couple egg yolks to
the wall you know
apparently that was lizzo night there
she would be great i love her i love
that outfit
yeah yeah those girls are fine as hell
that one lady looks like rick ross
[Laughter]
rickettsia ross right there now let's go
uh
aw buffalo wild wings i'm going into for
army navy man i'm going in i'm going to
go with uh
your dad's gonna punch in your fat nose
all right shout out to my boy lance
hecker he's a navy seal i'm going navy
man
[Music]
is